hello everybody hope they are good first
of all I want to apologize for the Audio
I know it's not the same but guys I'm
traveling so I don't have the some
equipment here as I have in home also
there is qu of Eco in this room so I'm
sorry for that and also I want to
apologize for yesterday's analysis it
wasn't great it was wrong so I'm sorry
for that but you know it's part of the
game um especially when your mind is not
what it has to be that in the charts
it's not only a technical analysis game
okay it's requires also a lot of mental
so you have to be focused and
concentrated and in the minute that you
lose the focus then you're going to make
a mistake and I'm going to show you my
mistake okay so my mistake was that I
had a
invalidation from the day before okay I
had this analysis it was quite clear to
me what I was betting on it was the idea
that we were going to see a r Trace
towards this liquidity pool over here
now I had a clear invalidation that it
was that if we pumped above the range
size that's basically this white line
I'm going to show you again range but if
we go above this level and we saw some
consolidation like this then that is
basically telling you that there is a a
flipped of resistance into support and
then you can see a bounce towards the
50% of the week okay so that of a
mistake you can see guys is clear in
validation but again if you are not
focused they're going to forget that you
have the the idea in mind and you're not
going to execute your trades well so go
stopped it doesn't happen frequent um in
fact the last time I think it was
several weeks ago but anyway I want to
show you the range go to the Daily time
frame I want to see herea clear okay so
you have a range here consolidation then
you have the break to the upside another
range you can see there that's the
deviation drop another range drop back
into the previous range just in some
consolidation and right now we are above
the range highs now the question is is
it going to hold are we going to hold
above the range SI because if we do that
means that is very likely that we see
continuation to the upside and that
would be for example the 100% of the
week back to 30k okay that's a
possibility but for that you need to
continue holding range SI this level and
the problem that I see here is that we
have this huge candle okay that's our
liquidity pool so the moment that we
lose the range size something like this
then that's the moment you can short
towards these levels over here okay um
that's what I think in the daily time
frame now for the day Traders including
myself we want to talk about the 1 hour
time frame first of all um at least I'm
happy that I said yesterday that this
week
was likely to get filled that was valid
for the week fill strategy you can see
there it goes basically there to the
dollar okay which is quite um
interesting and then it
dropped now the thing is that you know
you are holding the one or 50a and you
are also at range SI so in my opinion I
don't see any high probability trade
from here okay I took one today was a
scalp a short SC from here because I saw
basically that we hit the 50% of the
week I saw reaction from there okay and
then we were here and I said okay time
to uh write on this short sculp and I
want to the wors the one 15 may you can
see on Twitter the screenshot in case
but I've already recovered uh most of my
stop loss yesterday so I'm happy with
that but anyway we still have a couple
of days and I want to uh have have at
the end a good trading week I think it's
still possible but for that um I'm going
to only focus in high probility trades
like always and to maintain the focus so
the first thing that I see that could be
uh potentially giving us a high prity
rate is if we see a drop here okay below
the 150 M and then if we get a retrace
back again to it then that's a moment
where I'm going to take a short and I'm
going to Target lower and lower level
okay the first level is going to be
27,800 in a minute when I get to have
Capital they're going to see why okay
and the next level it's going to be the
450ma now this 4 50 m to be honest is
creeping up it's going upwards so that
means that the target could be the same
okay because it's um uh exponential uh
moving average so um it's all the time
every every time we have a candle close
had used to the current price okay so
it's going to continue creeping upwards
and maybe ends up being the same Target
otherwise um if we just have a very big
drop sorry then it's going to be two
different levels
27,800 and
27,600 at the moment okay so that's the
first High probity trade again for that
I need to see first the move down and
then I'm going to wait for the retrace
once I get the retrace that's when I'm
going to look for open for opening
shorts towards those two lower levels
okay that's the first thing now the
other idea that I have is that well I'm
going to tell you I always mention this
in the in the in the course but at the
50% of the week you want to see a clear
rejection or a bounce a bounce if the
week is to the downside or a rejection
if the week to the upside that's where
you're going to see a clear reaction so
now you've had a very long week here
that was with the false news of the
ETF
um that week has been filled the 50% of
of it so this week is in theory don't
now the market could could do price and
it would be justified in the chart okay
I would tell you yeah I mean it makes
sense you have a week you only 50% you
know you have green light for a for a
drop but if we manage to hold the one or
15a and we don't drop further and we
consolidate again around this
levels okay that's basically going to
tell me that the market makers
intentions are going to be to continue
filling this week more okay and that's
when we're going to Target the 100% of
the week so those are basically right
now my uh two scenarios that's what I'm
looking at this second SC the long
scenario to be honest I don't think it's
um for day trading because I think it's
going to take a few days to develop if
that's the case Okay I want to see some
consolidation
here in this
zone for at least 24 36 hours once I get
that then that's when I can get ready to
open Longs towards that week okay I hope
that's clear at this moment right now I
don't see any reason for opening trades
okay the T that you could have taken
were basically to F to fill this week
once you had the consolidation above
support that's bullish you could have
taken that trade that to the week you
could have taken a short from the 50% of
the week or if you miss to take the
short from here like me then halfway you
could have continue riding that towards
the 1 hour 50 May okay I don't see any
much more uh scenarios in um except if
you took along at the one or 50 me and
uh you you are very careful with the
stop loss okay in case you got surprised
and you see a red candle like this okay
so make sure that you would close your
short um your long sorry with a stop
loss okay just in case um it continues
going lower or um and you would take
that along with the idea that you're
going to see some consolidation here
before going towards that we all right
so I hope that's clear we're want to go
right now to high Capital we're want to
look at the levels
okay what in high Capital first of all
liquidation levels like always and we
can see $9 million worth of long
liquidations okay when you see the Delta
like this telling you that there are $9
million worth of long liquidations of
course this number can go higher but
what is basically telling you is that
the positional risk right now are Longs
okay it's the long position also here
look at the ratio total s liquidations
177 total long liquidations 626 that is
basically telling you that for every
short position there are four long
positions open so again you have to be
careful if you're are long because there
is a reason in this chart to drop price
low okay and now if you check the
liquidation levels right now they a beit
like a mess because you have here a lot
of liquidations at
29,300 you have also at 30k uh
30,500 31,000 there is qual of
liquidations to the upside and to the
downside you have two levels that to be
honest the spike is longer okay so we're
guessing that this number is bigger and
that's at
27,300 and 26,800 so uh this chart is
basically telling you be careful with
your Longs okay that's pretty much
everything that it's saying if you are
looking to go long you have to consider
that there is a risk right now okay now
in the 12 hours time frame this chart is
telling you the same all right you can
see here there was some liquidations at
28350 they go hit now if you look at the
chart there is a level here that is
27775 so 278 basically that it has a lot
of liquidation
so why not if we see the scenario of
losing the one or 50 m this is going to
be naturally your first Target 278
that's what I was telling you earlier
okay 7 Days time
frame uh I've looked at these charts
earlier um to be honest this chart right
now is a mess I wouldn't even uh pay
much attention to it the only thing you
have to know is that we have um some
liquidations at
32,000 which is quite interesting and to
the downside at
26,400 but those two levels are so so
far away that this looks like the 3
months time frame okay so I don't see um
anything else interesting in this chart
if you start to see a yellow bar
appearing a bit closer to price that is
when this chart is going to be important
okay but right now I think you only need
to know that that you have some
liquidations at 32,000 and at
26,400 and in the monthly time
frame the liquidations are
uh below the current price okay to the
downside so no much telling us okay the
thing that I find the most interesting
is this 12 hours time frame gu it's
going on with
27,800 okay so um that's kind of what
I'm thinking at the moment if we
consolidate again around the 50% of of
the week it's very likely that we're
going to Target the the 100% of the week
high probility trade to the to to the
upside that's a long but I that trade
take longer to develop and the other
high priority trade would be to the
downside if we lose the one or 50 m then
wait for the r Trace that's when you can
open a short and you can Target 27,800
and the 4our 50 May so that's is pretty
much everything guys thank you so much
for watching hopefully we get back into
some green trades after that uh mistake
yesterday um thank you so much for
watching and I'll see you soon